>> From Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Georgette Dorn: Good evening,
my name is Georgette Dorn
and I'm the chief of
the Hispanic division,
and these are a few words
in English for the cameras
because this is being
cybercast, so it's really
for posterity, not for you.
The program is going to
be in Spanish afterwards.
Welcome to Library of Congress.
Thanks to the Embassy of Chile
for having this wonderful event.
I want to thank Catalina
Gomez for organizing it.
The library has the most
extensive collection on Chile
in the United States because
there are books not published
in Chile, but books about Chile
in other countries like Germany,
Russia, China, etc. We also have
the voices of Gabriela Mistral
and Pablo Neruda, and,
of course, Gonzalo Rojas.
So, this program is
going to be presented
by Roberto Brodski Baudet
who's professor of Spanish
at Georgetown University
and also the [inaudible]
at the Embassy of Chile.
Roberto is a writer of
four novels and two more,
he tells me, that we don't have
in the collection, we have four
of them, and also, a writer of
film scripts and playwright.
I present here Roberto
Brodski Baudet.
[ Applause ]
>> Roberto Brodski:
May I speak in Spanish?
>> Georgette Dorn: Yes.
>> Roberto Brodski: Yes?
OK, bien. Bueno, introduzco
esta sesión de conversación a
solamente agradecerles
que estén acá,
agradecerle a Gwen Kirkpatrick
que tiene que viajar mañana y
que ha venido con nosotros.
Gwen ha sido chair del
departamento de español en
Georgetown, estuvo
muchos años en Berkeley,
entiendo que allí se
conoció con Gonzalo.
Hay un poema, de hecho yo
lo tengo aquí seleccionado,
un poema a Gwen Kirkpatrick de
Gonzalo Rojas que es muy bello.
Y entonces, queríamos por
supuesto reunir e invitarla a
conversar y a recordar un poco
a Gonzalo en este centenario
porque se trata de,
de una manera,
rendirle un pequeño
homenaje en el centenario.
Gonzalo Rojas nació en diciembre
del 2016 pero por un error,
entiendo de papeleo burocrático,
fue inscrito como
diciembre de 2017.
Entonces, durante todo el año,
Chile se ha estado celebrando el
centenario desde el diciembre de
2016 hasta diciembre de
2017 hemos estado celebrando
centenario de Rojas pensando en
este pequeño truco en el cual
cayó la biografía
de Gonzalo Rojas.
También en esta invitación en
este centenario hemos invitado a
Anna Deeny, que es traductora
y profesora de Georgetown,
traductora de poesía chilena.
Ha traducido en su vida
dos libros importantes,
esta obra por traducir de
Gabriela Mistral, Tala,
entiendo yo, ¿cierto?
Lo cual es magnífico para todos.
Y es una excelente
compañera de trabajo,
al menos para mí, en Georgetown.
También, y especialmente, está
con nosotros Gonzalo Rojas-May,
presidente de la Fundación
Internacional Gonzalo Rojas
en Chile.
La fundación está
en México también,
tiene un representante
en México,
y tiene un representante
en Europa.
Gonzalo Rojas-May es el
representante de la sección
chilena de la fundación y en
tanto tal representa el esfuerzo
de difundir y conservar
el patrimonio político de
Gonzalo Rojas.
Nuestra idea era invitarlo
justamente a la librería del
Congreso a este evento --
sabíamos que en la librería del
Congreso hay un archivo sonoro
muy importante de Gonzalo Rojas
y teníamos toda la intención de
compartirlo con él.
Vamos a escuchar luego algunas
poesías de ese archivo sonoro.
Es muy largo, son
dos horas y media.
No vamos a escucharlo entero
ni pudiésemos querer pero si
tenemos una selección de algunos
poemas que vamos a escuchar,
pero primero, por supuesto,
me gustaría invitar a Gwen,
a Gonzalo y a Anna a que
compartieran con nosotros
el estrado.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Roberto Brodski:
Cuidado que aquí hay una --
>> Gwen Kirkpatrick: Es
que yo ya [inaudible].
>> Roberto Brodski: Ah, OK.
Está bien.
¿Ahí está?
¿Se escucha bien?
Sí.
Bueno, quizás lo primero
es pedirle quizás a Gonzalo
Rojas-May, nuestro
ilustre invitadísimo,
que de unas palabras, que diga
cuáles un poco han sido las
expectativas y cuál ha sido un
poco también el sentimiento de
él digamos poder
representar, ¿cierto?,
el legado de Gonzalo
Rojas en este centenario.
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May: Bueno,
buenas tardes, buenas noches.
Muchas gracias por la invitación
a la biblioteca del Congreso y a
la Embajada de Chile
acá en Washington,
y también a Anne y a Gwen
por estar aquí hoy día.
Bueno, tengo que partir diciendo
que probablemente si mi padre
estuviera sentado estaría
no sé si molesto, digamos,
pero encontraría que esto es
un exceso, digamos [risas].
Cuando nosotros la
empezamos, como fundación,
a planificar y las cosas que
queríamos hacer a propósito de
su centenario, que tal como
contaba Roberto recién,
en estricto rigor se cumplió el
20 de diciembre de 2016 pero a
él lo inscribieron
en enero del '17,
entonces siempre
figuró esa confusión.
Y, además, a él le gustaba mucho
esta idea de haber nacido el
'17, decía que es un año mucho
más importante que el '16,
que en el año 1916
no había pasado nada,
y el año '17 era el año de
la revolución rusa [risas] y
entonces, bueno, por lo menos
hay algo, ¿no?, más importante.
Bueno, nosotros empezamos
a pensar como fundación qué
queríamos hacer.
La verdad es que nuestra
principal idea fue trabajar en
proyectos que tuvieran que ver
con difundir en otros idiomas
fuera del castellano.
Y fue así como nos embarcamos
en diversos proyectos para hacer
traducciones en idiomas
tan diversos como el hindi,
el hebreo, el árabe, el
finés, el chino, el japonés.
Hemos hecho una serie de
traducciones durante estos
últimos dos años, en realidad
los proyectos comenzaron mucho
antes, y ese fue nuestro
principal y primer impulso,
¿no?
Tratar de alguna manera
de abrir esta voz,
esta palabra, de Iberoamérica.
Gonzalo Rojas siempre se
consideró ante todo un poeta
iberoamericano, más que
un poeta chileno, ¿no?
Él siempre fue partidario
de no tener fronteras.
Desde Canadá hasta el final
de América de donde era él y
soy yo.
Entonces, ese fue nuestro
proyecto inicial pero,
como suele ocurrir, se fueron
sumando amigos que nos fueron
pidiendo hacer cosas en
distintas partes, ¿no?
Y es así como hemos tenido
diversas actividades en varios
países, mesas redondas,
ponencias, documentales,
y la verdad es que por eso decía
tal vez a él le habría parecido
un poco excesivo todo
esto, o bastante excesivo.
Pero, más allá de eso, creo que
lo importante es la palabra,
¿no?
Yo creo que es lo
que nos une aquí,
y estamos en un lugar que
alberga palabra y de eso
se trata.
Y creo que este encuentro
es, para mí en particular,
muy singular en ese sentido.
O sea, estar en este lugar donde
yo sé que hay un registro muy
importante de su voz,
están sus libros,
el primer libro que publicó
él, La Miseria del Hombre,
si no me equivoco es el
volumen número uno o número dos,
está aquí en la biblioteca
y es un libro muy difícil de
conseguir porque se hicieron
solo 500 ejemplares y es un
libro fundacional en
su trabajo creador.
Y además porque él tuvo un
vínculo con Estados Unidos muy
importante, los 25 años que él
vivió fuera de Chile de forma
continua, vivió 15
años en Estados Unidos.
Este fue un país que le abrió
las puertas y es un país donde
él trabajó y fue muy
feliz, y escribió mucho.
Tuvo una tremenda producción
literaria durante los años que
vivió aquí en Estados Unidos
entre 1980 y 1994, 1995.
Así que, bueno, muchas
muchas gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
>> Roberto Brodski: Bueno,
me gustaría pasar la
palabra - ay, ¿toco algo?
Aquí suena como [risas]
minado todo el campo, ¿no?
Pero, bueno, quisiera darle
la palabra a Gwen que tiene
seguramente una experiencia
porque conoció directamente a
Gonzalo en ese tiempo que cuenta
Gonzalo Rojas-May donde fueron
los años '80 que fue justamente
el momento en que vino a grabar
a la librería del
Congreso, ¿cierto?
En 1980 estuvo acá
en Washington,
grabó el archivo sonoro,
y estuvo invitado a muchas
diversas universidades y fue,
entiendo yo, en ese período,
en esos 10 o 12 años,
donde conoció a Gwen, y Gwen era
entonces profesora en Berkeley,
entiendo, ¿no?
¿Sí? Sí.
>> Gwen Kirpatrick: Muy
bien, muchas gracias.
Es un gran placer
verte de nuevo, ¿no?
[risas].
Él visitó Berkeley también,
y Paula, los dos visitaron.
Si me acuerdo bien fue en
octubre la primera visita porque
es un mes tan espléndido en
esta zona y todos lo comentamos,
¿no?
Un cielo tan azul,
todo es brillante,
realmente es un mes
perfecto para Gonzalo Rojas,
para que venga a leer [risas].
Bueno, vino a Berkeley
y visitó mi clase,
que fue una clase de
poesía latinoamericana,
y realmente los alumnos
quedaron hechizados,
no fascinados sino hechizados,
nunca habían escuchado
nada, ¿no?
Yo me quedé así como una pobre
trapo [risas] de profesora.
Y me acuerdo muy bien que habló
mucho de la respiración y de la
poesía como vida, algunos de sus
temas constantes y leyó en ese
momento, en los '80, entre
otro poema, El Helicóptero,
porque todavía la dictadura de
Pinochet seguía en Chile y es un
poema, no sé si es del
momento, de esa época,
pero es un poema bien
político sobre la vigilancia,
sobre el espiar, y como digo
-- Y después los dos estaban,
Hilda y Gonzalo y al día
siguiente iba a darles un paseo
por San Francisco y él quería
visitar una tienda [inaudible]
en la square donde una vez hace
mucho había comprado [risas] una
gorra, ¿no?
Así de marinero griego, ¿no?
Esa gorra que tenía.
Y yo pensaba, "[inaudible]
square habrá cambiado mil veces
las tiendas", pero fuimos y, sí,
pudo conseguir exactamente
lo que quería.
Paseamos, fuimos a Muir Woods.
Si no lo conocen es un
parque de secoyas milenarios,
y quedaron muy impresionados,
quizás algo de Chile también
pero no muy lejos de San
Francisco pero es un
lugar de un silencio,
a pesar de tener
muchos turistas siempre,
pero la grandeza de la
naturaleza [inaudible] impone
un silencio.
Y después, dieron con Gonzalo
hijo y Paola y no me acuerdo en
qué año.
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May:
Eso fue en 1989,
y yo creo que fue como en
agosto o septiembre de 1989.
De eso me acuerdo muy bien.
Fuimos desde Utah, eso
es un viaje [risas].
>> Gwen Kirkpatrick:
[Risas] Es un viaje, ¿no?
Bueno, no quiero hablar
demasiado pero en ese momento
enseñaba en Brigham Young donde
enseño varios años en Utah,
Provo, y le encantó el
paisaje de allí ¿no?
La cordillera, no de los
Andes sino de los Rockies.
Y me dijo que tenía
una apariencia rojiza.
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May: Así es.
>> Gwen Kirkpatrick:
Mucho contraste.
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May:
Era un lugar precioso,
es un lugar precioso, sin duda.
Y en la noche se producía
un efecto que las montañas
brillaban porque habían grandes
minas de plata no explotadas,
y es una cosa impresionante,
muy bonito.
Entonces él se acordaba mucho de
Chile y del norte de Chile donde
el partió trabajando cuando
joven y vivió muchos años allí,
y yo creo que en buena
parte se quedó por eso,
por la belleza, por la luz.
Tuvo una casa, incluso, o
sea estuvo muy contento ahí.
>> Gwen Kirkpatrick: Bueno,
no hablé mucho de la poesía
[risas], de mi conocimiento,
mi suerte a conocerlo,
a ustedes y a Hilda.
Después puedo hablar de la
poesía [risas] quiero darle a
Anne ahora la oportunidad
de hablar.
Ella ha traducido un
poema para nosotros.
>> Roberto Brodski: Sí,
muchas gracias, Gwen.
Le quiero dar la palabra a Anna.
Entiendo que Anna estuvo
trabajando en la traducción de
las sílabas, un poema,
gesto heroico la verdad
porque anoche [risas] estaba
departiendo justo y hasta anoche
no lo había hecho y entonces,
supongo que hoy día estuvo
trabajando muy duro [risas].
Así qué tienes la palabra.
>> Anna Deeny Morales: Gracias
Roberto por esta preciosa
invitación la embajada
chilena, a Georgette,
y a Catalina por compartir este
espacio con nosotros y a Gwen
quien fue mi profesora también.
Todo nos vuelve a Berkeley
[risas] Berkeley, California,
y a los amigos que
han venido esta noche,
y a Gonzalo por estar
aquí con nosotros.
Pues, yo empecé a
pensar también,
siguiendo lo que empezó a decir
Gwen sobre la grandeza de la
naturaleza en la
poesía de Gonzalo Rojas,
y como impone un silencio, ¿no?
Es exactamente lo
que acabas de decir.
Además de esta idea que él
sentía que el espacio poético
era un espacio sagrado
y que la forma,
trabajar con esas formas era
un proceso sagrado que se
relacionaba con lo sagrado
de una vida misma, ¿no?
Una vida y el esfuerzo
de cada persona,
de su esfuerzo creativo.
Y además también lo
que dijo Gwen del aire,
Gwen mencionó el aire en una
conversación que tuvimos hoy y
yo había pensado más bien en
como Rojas usaba las vocales en
su poesía y como esas vocales se
relacionaban a su idea del ritmo
en su obra poética.
Así que decidí traducir el poema
"Las sílabas" porque él
consideraba las sílabas como el
elemento fundacional del
lenguaje, de un idioma, ¿no?
Y me interesó mucho la
etimología de la palabra
"sílaba" así que les leo un poco
de eso para poder apreciar más
el trabajo profundo que
desarrolló en este poema.
Así que sílaba viene del griego,
y la importancia del griego en
este caso que van a ver en el
poema es que el habla de una
idea de un origen de la sílaba y
para los griegos era particular
que ellos consideraban tanto las
vocales como las
consonantes como iguales,
se igualaban estos
sonidos en el griego,
y eso lo hereda el latín,
así que este poema es tanto
una reflexión sobre lo que él
considera en el castellano y en
su propio proceso de respiración
y de trabajo poético
como algo fundacional.
Pero también está hablando del
origen de su idioma y también de
cierto tipo de civilización,
¿no?
Y de tradición poética.
Bueno, es de sil, s-i-l quiere
decir "comprender, abrazar,
incluir" y se une a la palabra
"lambano" que quiere decir
"yo abrazo", "yo tomo", así que
"lambano" se relaciona en
español -- bueno, ya saben,
a "lamber" y esa palabra
y está en el poema, ¿no?
Así que es como toda una
relación que la hace entre un
procedimiento cósmico del sol
y los procedimientos mismos del
lenguaje y del cuerpo
y de la boca, además.
Y si no saben qué es una sílaba,
una sílaba se forma por la
vocal no por la consonante,
por la vocal, OK, por si acaso.
Así que les quiero leer primero
el poema en español para que
escuchen este aire y la
naturaleza de la cual
habló Gwen.
"Las sílabas" es del 1988.
"Y cuando escribas no
mires lo que escribas,
piensa en el sol que arde y no
ve y lame el Mundo con un agua
de zafiro para que el ser sea
y durmamos en el asombro sin el
cual no hay tabla donde fluir,
no hay pensamiento ni
encantamiento de muchachas
frescas desde la antigüedad de
las orquídeas de donde vinieron
las sílabas que saben
más que la música, más,
mucho más que el parto."
Y así termina el poema.
Así que aquí también él está
hablando tanto una tradición
etimológica, una
tradición poética,
además de algo que propulsa
dígamos de manera que Kristeva
había hablado, ¿no?
En "The Revolution
of Poetic Language",
algo que existe por
debajo del lenguaje,
antes del entendimiento
racional del lenguaje.
Así que es el aire,
es la respiración como algo
que nos une como seres humanos,
como algo que funde nuestra
poética y nuestro ser antes de
un racionalismo, ¿no?
Antes de los significados
de las palabras.
Así que mi desafío en la
traducción era tratar de
mantener cierta asonancia
en el poema,
tratar de no enfatizar
las consonantes,
lo cual es mucho más
difícil en inglés,
y bueno solamente
usar consonantes como
"b" que son bilabial
sounded fricatives [risas].
Creo me acuerdo de eso de la
clase de la clase de [inaudible]
en Berkeley, en la
clase de Lingüística.
No, porque es importante, ¿no?
Y una consonante que me gusta
mucho en el inglés es la
"w" porque la "w" logra ser
consonante pero sin que se
toquen las partes
de la boca, ¿no?
OK. "Syllables" "And
when you write,
don't see what you've written,
think how the sun burns
without sight and laps the
world with sapphire water,
so that Being be and so,
we dose off in wonder
without which there's
no table for the flow,
no young woman's spell
under which to fall fresh
from antiquity, from orchids
from where syllables come
that know more than music,
more, so much more than birth."
Así que esa es la
traducción, y mi regalo.
[ Aplausos ]
Gracias.
>> Roberto Brodski:
Muchas gracias.
Qué increíble, ¿no?
[risas], esa hermosa traducción.
Hay una selección que hicimos
con Catalina a quien debo
agradecer, también a Georgette
por supuesto por toda la
organización del homenaje,
que es interesante porque
nosotros designamos el homenaje
como "Los 100 años
de un relámpago",
quizás por el título, ¿no?
Y justamente uno de los libros
que seleccionó Gonzalo Rojas
para grabar acá en
la librería es
"Del relámpago" justamente,
¿no?
Y vamos a escuchar dos
textos que él va a recitar.
>> Gonzalo Rojas: "La piedra"
"Por culpa de nadie habrá
llorado esta piedra.
Habrá dormido en lo aciago"
[ Inaudible ]
>> Roberto Brodski: Sí [risas].
"de su madre esta piedra
precipicia por unimiento
cerebral al ritmo de donde
vino llameada y apagada,
habrá visto lo no visto con los
otros ojos de la música, y así,
con mansedumbre, acostándose
en la fragilidad de lo informe,
seca la opaca, abrase anoche
sin ruido de albatros contra la
cerrazón ido.
Vacilado no habrá por esta
decisión de la imperfección de
su figura que por oscura no vio
nunca nadie porque nadie las ve
nunca a esas piedras que son de
nadie en la excrecencia de una
opacidad que más bien las enfría
ahí al tacto como nubes neutras,
amorfas, sin lo airoso
del mármol ni lo lujoso de
la turquesa,
¡tan ambiguas si se quiere,
pero por eso mismo, tan próximo,
vacilado no; habrá salido por
demás intacta con su traza
ferruginosa y celestial, le
habrá a lo sumo dicho al árbol:
"Adiós árbol que me
diste sombra; al río:
Adiós río que hablaste por mí --
lluvia, adiós, que me mojaste.
Adiós, mariposa blanca.
Por culpa de nadie habrá
llorado esta piedra."
[ Inaudible ]
"Gato negro a la
vista" Es una visión.
[ Inaudible ]
"Gato, peligro de muerte,
perversión de la siempreviva,
gato bajando por lo áspero,
gato de bruces por lo pedregoso,
en ángulo recto,
sangrientas las úngulas,
gato gramófono en el
remolino de lo áfono,
gato en picada de bombardero,
gato payaso sin alambre en
lo estruendoso del Trópico,
arcángel negro y torrencial de
los egipcios, gato sin parar,
gato y más gato correveidile
por los peñascos, gato luz,
gato obsidiana, gato
mariposa, gato carácter,
gato para caer guardabajo,
peligro."
[ Inaudible ]
>> Roberto Brodski:
Muy bueno, ¿no?
[ Aplausos ]
>> Roberto Brodski: ¿Tú
te acordabas, Gonzalo,
de esta [risas] recitación?
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May: Sí.
¿Puedo comentar algo
de los dos poemas?
El primer poema, que se llama
"La piedra", la piedra existe.
Es una piedra enorme,
muy grande.
Cuando a nosotros como familia
nos permitieron volver a Chile
el año '80, mi padre, bueno,
trató de conseguir trabajo
en Chile durante unos meses,
no consiguió nada y por eso fue
que se vino a Estados Unidos
durante los siguientes años como
ya conté y siempre quiso tener
algún lugar, ¿no?
Habíamos vivido en Concepción y
estaba viendo donde se quedaba,
entonces por un lado había
pensado quedarse en Chillán,
de donde es mi familia
materna, de donde era mi madre,
pero había un lugar cerca de
Chillán que a él le encantaba,
que era cerca de las
Termas de Chillán,
un gran centro de ski,
un lugar muy bello.
Y un día andaba paseando en auto
y se bajó al lado de un río con
mi madre y conmigo.
Y de repente vio este río,
que es un río impresionante
que se llama el Río Renegado,
un río precioso.
Y había como una punta de barco,
entonces fue a averiguar
si vendían ese lugar,
y lo encontró y lo vendían,
pero empezó a pensar,
" Si ¿lo voy a comprar?,
si ¿no lo voy a comprar?,
si ¿para qué lo iba a comprar?"
Y dudaba, ¿no?
Entonces, durante los siguientes
dos o tres días subió desde
Chillán nuevamente a
mirar a este lugar,
y no estaba muy convencido hasta
que de pronto vio la piedra.
Y vio la piedra y le
escribió el poema a la piedra.
Y allí, construyó una casa,
que era una casa preciosa que
tenía tres pisos de altura,
que estaba sobre el río.
Había un balcón que la
circundaba y él se sentaba a
pescar desde el balcón
sobre el río.
Era un lugar increíble [risas]
y, bueno, desafortunadamente,
la casa se quemó hace unos años.
Estamos tratando ahí
de reconstruirla.
Y después que murió, él
está enterrado en Chillán,
en un cementerio
que es muy bonito,
donde hay muchos
artistas chilenos --
Chillán es una ciudad curiosa,
nacieron muchos artistas
muy famosos de Chile y de
Iberoamérica, del mundo.
Y bueno, él está enterrado ahí,
y su tumba está entre dos
cipreses, muy bonitos,
y entre los dos cipreses
pusimos la piedra.
Entonces, está piedra
lo acompaña,
duerme ahí con él,
la piedra del pueblo.
Y el gato existía.
Vivíamos en Caracas y
vivíamos en un edificio,
y detrás del edificio había como
un cerrito y todas las tardes
había un gato que bajaba, ¿no?
Bajaba y subía.
Y bajaba por una pendiente y
muchas veces como que se caía,
rodaba, pero el gato
volvía a subir, ¿no?
Y ese es el gato del poema.
>> Roberto Brodski: Que buena.
Quisiera preguntarle a Gwen un
tema que me parece que hemos
estado conversando en estos
días, que es un poco, digamos,
si uno pudiese hacer un
mapa, una cartografía.
¿cierto? De la poesía
latinoamericana,
¿dónde ubicar a Gonzalo Rojas?
¿En qué lugar?
Porque hay un cierto
clasicismo en él, ¿cierto?
¿Dónde ubicarlo?
¿Cómo ponerlo en esa
cartografía eventual, digamos?
>> Gwen Kirkpatrick: Bueno,
como él mismo dijo varias veces,
no se adhirió a ninguna
escuela, ¿no?
Muchas veces dicen que era de la
generación de [inaudible] de '38
en Chile, ¿no?, de mucha
influencia del surrealismo,
pero al leer su poesía
no pensamos, "Bueno,
es un poeta muy influido por
el surrealismo" Entonces,
estaba leyendo este
folleto de Fondo de Cultura,
tiene un artículo, un ensayo
de José Emilio Pacheco,
muy buen escritor fantástico y
muy buen crítico también, ¿no?
Y él habla de la unidad de
la poesía de Gonzalo Rojas,
que no importa tanto
la cronología,
no pasa de surrealista a
realista a posmoderno, ¿no?
Y tenía una cita que dice:
"Hay poetas que cambian y hay
poetas que ahondan" Y para él,
Gonzalo Rojas era ese poeta que
tenía una veta [fonético] vital
que podía volver a esas fuentes
con muchas variaciones, ¿no?
Pero yo creo que la cosmovisión,
si podemos decirlo
de esa manera,
hay muchas otras palabras
quizás mejores, ¿no?
Era una creencia en el
mundo, en los seres humanos,
en la naturaleza, y también,
como dijiste, lo sagrado,
sea religioso o no, pero de
alguna manera hay algo sagrado
en el mundo, hay algo
sagrado en el ser humano,
y ¿dónde ponemos
eso en la cronología?
Es muy difícil, ¿no?
Porque aún sus primeros poemas
tienen algo de la brevedad ¿no?
y de --
Bueno, no son todos
breves sus versos.
No es todo breve [risas]
pero hay algo de --
no es ligereza pero hay
algo que no pesa, ¿no?
Aire, ¿no?
Pero eso es de "La
piedra" también.
Copié otra cosa de su discurso
al recibir el Premio Nacional,
hay una foto de él
con Patricio Aylwin,
fue un momento supongo
para recibirlo, ¿no?
Y habló del hombre o del
ser humano como homo ludens,
y homo eligens, que a la vez uno
puede tomar de muchos lugares,
¿no?
Hay que gozar de
lo que se nos da,
y a la vez reconocer lo
sagrado en cualquier lugar.
Y dijo eso de escuchar el
zumbido del principio y eso es
algo que creo que podemos decir
para caracterizar su poesía.
Yo no tengo un nicho donde
lo puedo poner, ¿no?
Algo me acuerdo, sin embargo, es
algo que dice del surrealismo.
No es una mente surrealista,
pero dijo que le animó muchísimo
descubrir el surrealismo por la
actitud lírica y por el deseo
de poblar la zonas indecibles,
un poco de lo que
decía antes, ¿no?
Que como decimos lo
indecible y eso le inspiró,
eso podría ir más allá, más allá
que la costumbre reconocible en
la poesía.
Entonces [inaudible] [risas].
Yo no sé, hay como --
[diafonía] Es interesante.
Es muy distinto de Pacheco.
Pacheco es muy influido
por los ingleses,
por los norteamericanos,
pero tiene algo parecido,
no es el tono, pero
es el silencio.
Respetan el lugar vacío donde
pueden surgir otras cosas.
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May: Yo estoy
muy de acuerdo con lo que
dice Gwen.
Efectivamente, la poesía
de Gonzalo Rojas es -
el silencio ocupa un
lugar fundamental.
Cuando él trabajaba en la
edición de su poesía --
yo fui testigo de eso,
tuve el privilegio -
y a la hora de editar cuando
iba a sacar un nuevo libro,
el espacio en blanco entre los
versos para él era fundamental
porque en el fondo tenía que ver
con el ritmo respiratorio pero
también con la necesidad
de una suerte de vuelta,
de ensimismamiento pero un
ensimismamiento necesario.
Y al mismo tiempo - claro,
yo creo que hasta eso ha sido
muy estudiado y dicho aquí,
la presencia de lo religioso,
pero no es una religiosidad
militante.
No, es el juego de lo religioso,
de lo que está más
allá de lo desconocido,
y hay muchísimos poemas.
Ayer, Anne me preguntaba cuál
eran mis poemas favoritos.
Bueno, hay muchos que me gustan
pero hay uno en particular que
se llama "Quedeshím Quedeshóth"
y que probablemente muestra lo
que decía recién también
Gwen, de una manera notable.
Este vínculo entre el eros,
lo sagrado, la transcendencia,
el juego, y es un
poema bien surrealista.
Es un gran texto.
[Inaudible].
Desde luego, bueno,
es que ese es.
O sea, "Quedeshím
Quedeshóth" es un texto que -
a mi padre le gustaba
mucho las enciclopedias.
Entonces, de vez en cuando
o con mucha frecuencia,
iba a librerías de viejos.
Y aquí también yo tuve la suerte
de estar presente cuando pasó
esto, fuimos en Salt Lake City
a una librería de viejos que
iba mucho.
Entonces, estaba mirando libros
cada cierto tiempo y compraba
algo, y de repente había llegado
nueva una enciclopedia, ¿no?
Era una enciclopedia
británica de 1920, ¿no?
Todavía son las tapas de
color verde, muy bonita.
[Inaudible] [risas] claro,
y bueno, abre este volumen.
Sacó un volumen al azar, y
me dice, "Mira, que raro.
Esto dice "Quedeshím
Quedeshóth" ¿Qué cosa es esto?"
Entonces, bueno, empezó a leer y
Quedeshím Quedeshóth en fenicio
significa "cortesana
del templo",
y le gustó tanto
este sonido, ¿no?
Y empezó a pensar en eso,
bueno, y escribió ese texto.
>> Roberto Brodski: A lo mejor
lo podemos leer para terminar.
>> Anna Deeny Morales:
Pues para mí igual,
o sea dijeron tanto tan precioso
que qué podría añadir a eso
[risas] excepto que la falta del
peso de la cuál hablas para mi
está en esta idea que él elabora
a lo largo de su poética y es
que siempre, cada momento es
un momento del instantáneo,
del nacimiento del tiempo, del
nacimiento de ese momento, ¿no?
Así que mantiene como cierta
ligereza en eso, ¿no?
O sea, es nunca caer.
Y creo que eso también, en el
nivel de la técnica poética,
se relaciona al énfasis
en las vocales, ¿no?
También algo que me impresiona
de su obra es su énfasis en el
yo que es testigo de sí mismo.
El primer libro de
48, nunca vacila.
No tiene esta ansiedad
que por ejemplo,
la gran ansiedad de Octavio
Paz, que era el perder el yo,
perder la distinción
entre un yo,
tanto de manera física y de
manera de la identidad como el
vaciar de cierto tipo de
definición de la palabra, ¿no?
Y él nunca se preocupa por eso.
No hay ninguna ansiedad en
esta idea que el Yo no puede
ejercerse sobre un mundo.
Y tal vez de ahí podemos pensar
en cierta política, ¿no?
Que el Yo se conoce, que
el Yo tiene un esfuerzo,
que el Yo puede hablar, ¿no?
Y eso es algo importante
en el siglo XX, ¿no?
Pensando que el Yo - si pensamos
en una palabra que se vacía más
que otra en el siglo
XX, es el Yo [risas].
Y el sigue manteniendo y eso es
cierto tipo de ética, también,
de la responsabilidad
de un individuo.
Y él traza eso a
través de su poesía.
O sea, el idioma es de todos
pero no es solamente de todos,
es de uno mismo y uno tiene
esa capacidad creativa.
>> Gwen Kirkpatrick:
Quería decir una cosa más.
Era un hombre muy erudito y
sin embargo uno no dice en sus
poemas, "Vamos a
buscar el diccionario.
Vamos a Google porque no
entendemos lo que se dice aquí"
pero llevaba esa erudición
sin mostrarla, ¿no?
No pesaba, no era un bloque
para los lectores Pero informaba
su pensamiento.
Y algo que no sabía es
estudiar un poco más puede --
como dijste una vez,
tenía una vida muy rica.
Vivía en muchas partes, en
la China, en la Alemania,
en los Estados Unidos, pero su
actividad en la universidad de
Concepción, eso yo creo que fue
muy pionero en eso de encuentros
de escritores, en los veranos,
que nadie había hecho eso antes.
¿En qué año fue?
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May:
Entre 1957 y 1962.
Sí, claro.
Además, reunía no solo
escritores sino que llevaba a
científicos, llevaba a
arquitectos, a hablar del mundo,
de América, no de América
Latina, de América en general.
Fueron todos los escritores del
movimiento beat de aquí, ¿no?
Fue la primera vez que
viajaron a América Latina.
Era muy impresionante
lo que lograba allí.
>> Roberto Brodski: Todo lo
que fue el boom pasó por allí.
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May:
Claro, así es.
>> Gwen Kirkpatrick: Entonces,
algo de empresario
[risas], ¿no?
De montar para que los otros
vieran es Chile y que ellos
pudieran conocer
otros del mundo.
Realmente, en esos
años es insólito.
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May:
Insólito, era increíble.
O sea, hacían estos encuentros
y por ejemplo iba donde la
compañía Phillips y conseguía
radios a transistores,
no sé si se acuerdan de
esas radios chiquitas,
y se conseguía miles,
textualmente, miles.
Y entonces se las regalaba a la
gente que vivía en el campo o
que trabajaban en las minas o
la gente más pobre que no tenía
radio en esa época porque
a través de la radio de la
universidad de Concepción
se transmitía todo esto,
que además tenía concierto,
y de esa manera hacía
un trabajo de difusión.
Era impresionante
las cosas que hacía.
>> Livestreaming.
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May: [Risas]
Livestreaming, ¡textualmente!
Así es.
>> Gwen Kirkpatrick:
Impresionante, realmente.
>> Roberto Brodski: No sé si hay
alguien del público que quiera
hacer alguna pregunta.
Aprovechar a Gonzalo
y a Gwen y a Anne.
>> La pregunta esa
de la cartografía,
¿con qué imagen
se quería vincular?
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May: Yo creo
que é tenía un vínculo verdadero
y profundo con los clásicos, y
yo creo que Anne fue muy lúcida,
muy sabia, cuando planteó esto
de la palabra que está detrás de
la palabra, ¿no?
La lengua que uno habla es hija
de una tradición y a él siempre
le interesó eso muchísimo.
O sea, de verdad leyó
a los griegos clásicos,
a los poetas romanos, y
con eso tenía una tradición
muy profunda.
Pero también leía a los
franceses y leía literatura
americana, inglesa, o sea -
>> Gwen Kirkpatrick: Alemana.
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May:
Alemana, muchísimo.
Tenía una biblioteca enorme de
30.000 volúmenes que para un
solo individuo es una
biblioteca muy grande, ¿no?
Y era una biblioteca
no solo de literatura,
era una gran biblioteca
de filosofía, de historia,
de sociología, de psicoanálisis.
Leía muchísimo, y volviendo
a la idea de la tradición,
yo creo que él tenía una visión,
como dije un rato
atrás, muy americana.
Me refiero a América como
América como continente, ¿no?
Y él apostaba mucho a eso
entonces siempre decía,
"Bueno" - claro tenía dialogo
con Octavio Paz, Javier Campos,
con Borges, pero él sentía
que América era la casa.
De hecho, así se llama,
el último encuentro que hacen en
Concepción del año '62 lo llama
así, "América es la casa"
porque esa era su idea, ¿no?
Entonces su tradición era una
tradición hacia atrás pero
también una apuesta hacia
adelante en ese sentido.
>> Roberto Brodski:
Es interesante porque esa
observación que tú haces es muy
paradójica porque un
avance a su era absoluta.
Era una vida grande, ¿no?
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May:
Absolutamente,
además que él siempre
hablaba - bueno,
fue exiliado en la
época de Pinochet,
pero hubo momentos en Chile que
por razones biográficas también
tuvo que pseudoescapar,
tomar cierta distancia
de conflictos que tenía,
sobre todo cuando era muy joven.
Entonces, no solo hablaba del
exilio sino que también hablaba
del intraexilio y además,
intraexilio que cada ser
humano pasa cuando sufre, ¿no?
Todos cuando sufrimos nos vamos
hacia adentro, nos recogemos,
y él decía que ese intraexilio
era muy valioso, ¿no?
Que no había que temerlo tanto,
que era un espacio sagrado,
que era un espacio de reflexión
y de creación muy importante.
[ Inaudible ]
[ Risas ]
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May: Que
es un pueblito muy chico,
eso es cierto.
>> ¿Es que no le gustaba?
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May:
No, no le gustaba.
Él estudiaba e iba a la
universidad pero en general no
le gustaba mucho eso es cierto.
>> [Inaudible] de expansión y
comprensión [inaudible], ¿no?
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May: Incluso
políticamente se le daba
mucho eso.
O sea, é siempre se declaró
que él no era un militante.
Nunca quiso hacer
poesía militante,
desde luego hay poesía de
contingencia de momento
histórico como testigo, pero
él nunca se definió como un
hombre político.
Nunca lo quiso ser, nunca
quiso ser militante.
Y eso le trajo múltiples
venturas y desventuras,
la dos cosas.
Los exilios de izquierda,
exilios de derecha,
momentos bien difíciles,
justamente por eso cuesta
siempre la libertad y eso lo
dice en muchos textos, habla
de la libertad permanentemente.
>> Sobre la influencia que
tuvo Berkeley en su poesía,
¿[inaudible] cuántos años?
>> Gwen Kirkpatrick:
No, visitas.
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May: Sí,
hizo visitas nada más.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May:
No, no, vivió aquí.
Bueno, él estuvo en Columbia,
estuvo en Nueva York,
y estuvo en Chicago, estuvo
en Pittsburgh, aquí cerca,
estuvo en Austin, y también
estuvo en Utah muchos años.
O sea dio una vuelta
por varios lugares.
>> Casi que le inspiró
en su poesía.
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May:
Mucho, muchísimo.
>> ¿Puedes hablarnos sobre eso?
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May:
Bueno, pasa lo siguiente.
Él nació en 1916, ¿no?
Entonces, entre 1948,
que publica su primer
libro cuando tiene 32 años,
después el siguiente libro
lo publica el año '64,
cuando tiene 47 años.
El tercer libro lo publica el
año '77 en Caracas cuando tiene
63, y después de eso publicó
en total como 70 libros,
y la mayor parte de esos textos
los escribió aquí en Estados
Unidos entre el '80 y el '95.
Siguió escribiendo
hasta el final,
hasta hay poemas de los
últimos seis meses antes de que
falleciera, o un
poquito después incluso.
Pero la producción que tiene en
Estados Unidos es impresionante,
y eso es lo que además
le da el impulso - bueno,
yo creo que probablemente habría
tenido los reconocimientos que a
él de verdad no le importaban
mucho, los habría tenido igual,
pero es a partir de eso que
empieza a figurar su nombre en
todas partes, ¿no?
Y bueno, todos estos premios
que venían uno detrás de otro.
Pero aquí escribió
muchísimo, mucho, mucho.
>> Georgette Dorn: Yo quería
mencionar que lo conocí en
Caracas en el año '77 en un
congreso cuando el premio Rómulo
Gallegos lo recibió
Carlos Fuentes,
y entonces lo invité para que
grabara la biblioteca y a los
tres años vino acá, en el año
'80, a grabar para el archivo.
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May:
Y allí debió haber
venido desde Nueva York.
Ahí estaba en Nueva
York, en el año '80,
y después de allí
fue a Pittsburgh.
>> Georgette Dorn: Pero vino
acá para estar en Georgetown y
en Maryland.
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May:
Claro, exactamente.
>> Roberto Brodski: Bueno,
muchísimas gracias por venir.
Ha sido una magnífica velada.
No sé si hay una
pregunta, más preguntas.
¿Sí?
>> Sí. Primero, esto
ha sido estupendo,
es muy bonito escucharlos y muy
bonito lo que están diciendo.
No sé si voy a poder formular
esto como una pregunta,
estoy pensando, todavía
procesando lo que han dicho.
Creo que tengo una pregunta
sobre algo que mencionaron los
tres, sobre la relación
entre la palabra --
no sé si es el aire o
la [inaudible] algo,
antes de la palabra pero también
está en la palabra y en la
[inaudible] con el mundo.
Gwen dijo el suspiro
al principio,
Anna se enfocaba en la sílaba,
Gonzalo varias veces
habló del silencio,
en la emisión sin peso, pero sin
embargo aún están las piedras,
[inaudible] entonces creo que
una pregunta específica sobre la
traducción si escuchar algo
antes o además de la palabra en
la palabra, si eso lo hace más,
o menos difícil de
traducir en este caso.
Y una pregunta para los tres,
si se escucha algo además de la
palabra en las palabras de los
poemas de Gonzalo Rojas,
si eso sugiere que las palabras
en sí son de alguna manera una
traducción de ese algo más.
No sé si se entiende.
>> Anna Deeny Morales: Bueno,
creo que para entender,
empezando por lo que había dicho
Gwen y también Gonzalo en cuanto
a su gran conocimiento, ¿no?
Y como un poeta muy
erudito, ¿no?
Que no tienes que
saber la etimología de
"sílaba" para entender
ese poema.
Creo que todas las
palabras se entienden,
no tienes que usar
un diccionario.
Los registros no salen tanto
de un conocimiento general de
vocabulario, del idioma.
Así que, por una
parte, está eso.
Y hay también una
contemporaneidad en su sintaxis
y en su uso de la gramática.
Así que eso podríamos
decir que es fácil.
En cuanto a la idea de un sonido
que venga antes de una palabra,
creo que la importancia de eso
tiene que ver con muchas cosas.
Para empezar, los sonidos que
vienen antes de la palabra,
de la formación de la palabra,
bueno, lo que llamamos ecolalia,
son sonidos que todos
los niños hacen.
Son sonidos - bueno, que por una
parte él está ubicándose en una
tradición griega del lenguaje,
cuando él habla de la sílaba
en particular como unidad
fundacional de la palabra, ¿no?
Por una parte, está eso.
Por otra parte está esta idea
que los sonidos de los niños -
todos los niños en el mundo
hacen los mismos sonidos y
tienen la capacidad de hablar
cualquier idioma hasta que ese
idioma viene limitado
por su región,
por los idiomas que se
hablan en su región,
hasta que entra ese niño en
cierto orden de comunidad.
Creo que ese momento antes es
un momento en el cual piensan
muchos poetas, ¿no?
Ese momento antes de la
limitación del lenguaje en un
idioma particular porque es un
momento de posibilidad absoluta,
de posibilidad de
significados absolutos,
es un momento de libertad, ¿no?
Y es un momento que podríamos
decir que se equivale a la
respiración, cuando el
niño, "Blah, blah, blah,
ma, ma, ma, ma", ¿no?
Así que hay una libertad en
eso, hay una democracia en eso,
hay una universalidad
ene sa idea.
También por otra parte --
pero yo no sé si ustedes
sienten esto en su poesía -
él no echa de menos ese momento.
Ese momento continúa existiendo.
Mientras que otro poeta si
echaría de menos esa pérdida de
ese estado pre formación de la
palabra, de entrar en el orden,
bueno, la [inaudible]
orden del padre,
el separamiento de cuerpo de la
mamá y entrar en el orden del
padre, ¿no?
Él no lamenta ese cambio,
simplemente lo propone como algo
que sigues respirando dentro de
las formas poéticas, ¿no?
En cuanto a la traducción
de eso, pues,
es ver cómo funcionan
esos sonidos en el inglés,
pero tenemos que siempre tomar
en cuenta que dentro del inglés
respiran muchos idiomas, ¿no?
El francés además de todos los
españoles que existen en los
Estados Unidos, los alemanes,
así que es pensar cómo se puede
sonar esa lectura de ese poema
en inglés.
>> Gwen Kirkpatrick: No
puedo agregar nada [risas].
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May:
Yo tampoco.
Estaba pensando que a lo
mejor - sí, ya es tarde.
Estaba pensando, "¿Y con
qué poema contestar eso?"
Y leer un poema, estaba
tratando de ver y no me acuerdo.
Déjame ver si encuentro
rapidito, y ahí terminamos.
Esta cosa es como un ladrillo
[risas] Déjame ver si encuentro
- ya había hablado de "Quedeshím
Quedeshóth" pero vamos a ver si
podría ser este.
Este poema se llama
"Tabla de Aire".
"Consideremos que la imaginación
fuera una invención como lo es,
que esta gran casa de aire
llamada Tierra fuera una
invención, que este espejo
quebradizo y salobre ideado a
nuestra imagen y semejanza
llegara más lejos y fuera la
invención de la invención,
que mi madre muerta y sagrada
fuera una invención rodeada de
lirios, que cuanta agua anda en
los océanos y discurre secreta
desde la honda y bellísima
materia vertiente fuera una
invención, que la respiración
más que soga y asfixia fuera una
invención, que el cine y todas
las estrellas, que la música,
que el coraje y el martirio,
que la Revolución
fuera una invención,
que esta misma tabla de aire
en la que escribo no fuera sino
invención y escribiera
sola estas palabras.
[ Aplausos ]
Bueno, muchas gracias.
>> Roberto Brodski: Bueno,
muchísimas gracias a
nuestros invitados.
Gracias a Georgette
y a [inaudible].
>> Gonzalo Rojas-May:
Sí, muchas gracias.
[ Aplausos ]
[ Inaudible ]
>> Catalina Gomez: Sí, la
salida es ahora por detrás,
bajan por el ascensor, toman
la derecha y [inaudible].
[ Inaudible ]
>> Catalina Gomez: Hay
que salir por atrás.
>> Roberto Brodski: Hay
que salir por atrás,
dice Catalina [risas].
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.